when it comes down to Ai and computers I
think and I don't think that at the
present moment computers are conscious
but people are already forming intimate
relationships with AIS and are therefore
almost irresist it's almost irresistible
they're compelled to to increasingly
feel that these are conscious entities
and I think we are quite close to the
point when the legal system will have to
take this into account
that even though I don't think computers
have Consciousness I think we are close
to the point the legal system will start
treating them as conscious entities
because of this social convention
what to use uh social convention
just a funny little side effect a little
artifact or is it fundamental to what
Consciousness is because if it is
fundamental then it seems like AI is
very good at forming these kinds of deep
relationships with humans yeah and
therefore it will be able to be a nice
Catalyst for
integrating itself into these social
conventions of ours it was built to
accomplish that yeah we are designing
and you know all these arguments between
a natural selection and uh uh
creationism intelligent design
um as far as the past go all entities
evolved by natural selection the funny
thing is when you look to the Future
more and more entities will come out of
intelligent design not of some God above
the clouds but of our intelligent design
and that the intelligent design of our
clouds of our Computing clouds they will
Design more and more entities and this
is what is happening with AI it is
designed
to be very good at forming intimate
relationships with humans
and uh um in many ways it's already
doing it almost better than human beings
in some situations you know when two
people talk with one another one of the
things that kind of uh um makes the
conversation more difficult is our own
emotions
you're saying something and I'm not
really listening to you because there is
something I want to say and I'm just
waiting until you finish I I can put in
a word or I'm so obsessed with my anger
or irritation or whatever that I don't
pay attention to what you're feeling
this is one of the biggest obstacles in
human relationships and computers don't
have this problem because they don't
have any emotions of their own so you
know when a computer is talking to you
it can be the most it can focus a
hundred percent of its attention is on
your what you're saying and what you're
feeling because it has no feelings of
its own and paradoxically this means
that computers can
fool people into feeling that uh oh
there is a conscious entity on the other
side an empathic entity on the other
side because the one thing everybody
wants almost more than anything in the
world is for somebody to listen to me
somebody to focus all their attention on
me like I want it for my spouse for my
husband from my mother for my friends
for my politicians listen to me listen
to what I feel and they often don't and
now you have this entity which a hundred
percent of its attention is just on what
what I feel and this is a huge huge
Temptation and I think also a huge huge
danger well the interesting Catch-22
there is you said somebody to listen to
us yes we want somebody to listen to us
but for us to respect that somebody
they sometimes have to also not listen
it's like
um they kind of have to be an
sometimes they have to have moods
sometimes they have to have like
self-importance and confidence and and
uh we should have a little bit of fear
that they can walk away at any moment
there should be a little bit of that
tension so it's like absolutely but but
I mean the thing is if
inattention is good for a conversation
because then you feel challenged oh I
need to grab this person's attention you
can program the AI to have 17 exactly 17
in attention not one percentage more or
less or it can by trial and error
discover what is the the ideal
percentage again you you can create over
the last 10 years we have creating
machines for grabbing people's attention
this is what has been happening on
social media
now we are designing machines for
grabbing human intimacy
which in many ways is much much more
dangerous and scary already the machines
for grabbing attention we've seen how
much social and political damage they
could do by in when you buy kind of
distorting the public conversation
machines that are superhuman in their
abilities to create Intimate
Relationships this is like psychological
and social weapons of mass destruction
if we don't
regulate it if we don't train ourselves
to deal with it it could destroy the
foundations of human society